les écoles ont voulu redonner aux
finissants du secondaire un peu de ce
que la coved 19 leurs abonnés je me suis
quand même à des propos aujourd'hui pour
célébrer c'était l'occasion de sortir
les robes du bal qui n'a pas eu lieu
bois des filion a voulu en faire un peu
plus pour les finissants 2020 de l'école
secondaire rive nord on a cité avec les
sirènes la pandémie n'aura pas eu raison
de tous les rituels et tradition
même si c'est en petit groupe que doit
se dérouler la collation des grades à
montréal à l'école secondaire saint luc
ça commence sous les chapiteaux regarde
comme ça puis il fait très chaud mais je
vous trouve très beau
puis tout se fait selon un parcours
précis en respectant les marques au sol
c'est comme en partie oui mais pas de
masque
oui c'est bizarre mais à pas il est
quand même c'est tous mes amis que j'ai
rencontrés à l'école tous ces gens là
sont ma famille je les aime tellement
même les profs c'est pas comme la pire
chose qui pourrait arriver ont sonné
entre ne sors moi on est en train de
dire au revoir
des profs sont émus je veux donner
décalé les élèves alors c'est un peu
difficile mais écoutez on n'a pas le
choix
les élèves le comprennent assez bien on
se donne des câlins virtuels
quatre mois c'est une vie avec de
secondaire 5
c'est on avait des voyages de planifier
on avait des sorties planifiées des
projets dans mon cours de chimie dont il
y avait beaucoup beaucoup de véhicules
qu'on a raté presque tous ses élèves
l'ocs ont été mes élèves
mais petit en secondaire comme
enseignante là c'est ce que j'ai vu
depuis pâques à l'epo de faux drapeau
chemin pas demandé d'aidé
deux signatures dans les albums la fin
d'année aura été virtuel merris deux
motions aujourd'hui sont bien réels ici
anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal